next
i want to talk about how do we train
graph neural networks
right so far we talked about how do we
augment the feature vector of the node
and how can we augment the graph
structure
and we talked about how to augment the
graph structure by adding edges to
improve message passing
or how do we drop edges to
increase the efficiency especially in
natural graph social networks where you
have high degree
nodes you don't want to aggregate from
the entire neighborhood of the node but
you want to kind of carefully subselect
the part of the network to aggregate
from so this is the
reason why you want to do these
augmentations now i want to talk more
about
how do you do the training how do you
deal with the outputs how do you define
the loss functions measure performance
and so on
so the next talk is how do we train a
gnn right like what kind of learning
objective do we want to define
and um how are we going to uh do
uh all this uh together
so gnn training pipeline has the
following
steps right so far we talked about the
input graph
we talked about how to define the graph
neural network and we talked about
how the graph neural network produces
node embeddings
what we haven't talked about yet is how
do you get from node embeddings to the
actual prediction
and then once you have the predictions
how do you evaluate them
based against some ground truth labels
and how do you compute the laws
or how do you define the laws the
discrepancy between the
predictions and the true labels right
so far we only said aha gnn produces a
set of
node embeddings right which means that
this is a representation of node
l add the final layer layer l
of the graph neural network and i can
think of this as you know some
representations some vectors attached to
the nodes of the network
now the question is uh you know how is
this
second part defined what do we do here
in terms of prediction heads
evaluation metrics where do the labels
come from
and what is the loss function we are
going to optimize
so let's first talk about the prediction
head right
uh prediction head this means the output
of the g
of the of the final model um can have d
we can have different prediction heads
we can have node level prediction heads
we can have
uh link level edge level as well as
entire
graph level prediction heads so let me
talk about
this first so for
prediction head the idea is that
different tasks
require different types of prediction
outputs right as i said we can have a
entire graph level individual node level
or
edge level which is a pairwise between a
pair of nodes
so for node level prediction we can
directly make prediction using node
embedding so
basically after a graph neural network
computation we have a d dimensional node
embedding
for every node in the network um and if
for example we want to make a kva
prediction
which would be basically a
classification of nodes among k
different classes or k different
categories
um this would be one way or perhaps you
want to regress
uh against ten uh sorry k different
targets k different
uh characteristics of that node uh the
idea
would be quite uh simple we just say um
you know the
output uh head of uh for a given node
is simply some uh matrix time the times
the
final embedding of that node right so
this basically means that
w will will map node embeddings uh from
this embedding space
to the to the prediction uh to the
prediction space to the in this scale
case let's say a k dimensional output
because we are interested in
a k dimensional um uh
prediction so a k way uh prediction
um in order one more thing i will add
for the rest of the lecture i'm going to
use this
hat symbol to denote the predicted value
versus the ground truth value right so
whenever i use a head this means this is
a value
predicted by the model and then i can go
and compare
y hat with y where y is the true
true label and y hat is the predicted
uh label right and now that i have y hat
i can compare it to y and i can compute
the loss the discrepancy between the
prediction uh and the truth
this is for node level tasks for edge
level tasks
we have to make a prediction using pairs
of node embeddings right so
again suppose you're gonna make a k-way
prediction
then what we need is a is a prediction
head that takes the embedding of one
node and the other node
and returns uh y-hat now y-hat is uh
defined on pairs of nodes this would be
for example for
a link prediction so let me tell you
what are some
options for creating this uh
edge level head for prediction
so one option is that we simply
concatenate
uh embeddings of nodes u and v and then
apply a linear
uh layer a linear transformation right
and we have seen this
uh this idea already in graph attention
right we said when we computed the
attention between nodes u and v
we simply concatenated the embeddings
pass them through a linear layer
um and that gave us uh the prediction of
the attention
score between a pair of nodes here we
can use the
same the same idea where basically we
can take the embeddings of u and we
concatenate them basically just join
them together and then
apply a linear predictor on top of this
so basically
multiply this with a matrix and perhaps
sent through a
non-linearity or anything like that like
a sigmoid or soft max
if we like right so uh idea would be
that um
the prediction is simply um you know
it's a linear function that then takes
the
um h1 uh h of u and h of v concatenates
them
um and up and maps this uh uh
to the 2d dimensional embedding into a
k way uh prediction or a k dimensional
uh
output another idea
rather than concatenating is also we can
do
a dot product right so we basically say
our prediction between
u and v is simply a dot product between
their embeddings
if i simply do the dot product between
the embeddings then i get a single
scalar output so this would be a one-way
prediction like
link classification or link prediction
is there a link or not right so
basically just a
one variable kind of binary
classification
now if i want to have a kva prediction
if i want to for example predict
the type of the link and i have multiple
types uh
then i would basically have this kind of
almost similar to this kind of multi-hat
prediction where basically i can have
a different uh uh matrix uh
w that is strainable um and i have one
for every output class right so for
every uh output
uh class i would have a different matrix
w that essentially the way you can think
of it is it takes
uh let's say the vector u and then it
transforms it by
shrinking or extending rotating and
translating it
and then uh multiplying that that with a
h of
v so it's still a dot product but the
input vector gets transformed right and
um every every class gets to learn its
own transformation
how to basically uh rotate uh translate
uh and shrink or expand the vector
so that the dot product um is uh is uh
such that the predict that the value the
output values
uh are well um are well predicted
and then right once i have a prediction
for every of the classes
i can simply concatenate them and that's
my final prediction
right so for kva prediction in binary
just to summarize
i can define this matrix w one per
output class
and then learn this type of linear
predictor based on dot product
and then the last thing to discuss is
how do we do
graph level prediction right
here we want to predict using all the
node embeddings in our graph
right and again let's suppose we want to
make a kva prediction
so what we want is we want to have this
prediction head
that makes one prediction on the entire
graph
so what this means is we have to take
the individual node embeddings
right for every node and somehow
aggregate them
to find the embedding of the graph so
that we can then make a prediction
right so in this sense this uh head for
graph
uh prediction graph level prediction is
similar to the aggregation function in a
gnn layer right we need to
aggregate all these embeddings of nodes
to create a graph level embedding and
then make a
graph level uh prediction so let me tell
you
how you can define this uh graph
prediction head there are many options
uh for us to do this so one is to do
global
mill pulling right so basically you take
the embeddings of all the nodes
and you average them that would be one
possibility
another possibility is max pooling where
you would take
take coordinate wise maximum across
the embeddings of all the nodes um and
then
another option is that you do summation
based pooling where you basically just
sum up
the embeddings of all the nodes in the
graph
and this will depending on the
application and depending on the graph
graphs you are working with uh different
uh
options are going to work better you
know
mean pulling is interesting because the
number of nodes does not really play the
role so if
if you want to compare graphs that have
very different
sizes then perhaps mean pooling is the
best option
but if you really want to also
understand how many nodes are there in
the graph
and what is the structure of the graph
then sum based pulling
is a better option of course there are
also more advanced
graph pulling strategies and i'm just
going to give you next an idea
how how you can improve this
the reason why we may want to improve
this is that the issue is that global
pulling over a large graph
will use a lot of information and i want
to illustrate what i mean by this is
by with this simple toy example where
you can think
that we have nodes that have only one
dimensional embeddings right so the
embeddings are just a single number
and imagine i have two graphs in one
case you know i have the values like
minus one node one has embedding minus
one node two has embedding minus two
node three zero you know four has
embedding one and
five has embedding uh two and perhaps i
have a different graph
where embeddings are very different
right it's like minus 10 minus
20 0 10 and 20. right and i can say look
clearly
g1 and g2 have very different node
embeddings their structures could be
very very different
but if i do any kind of global sum based
pulling for example
if i sum or if i take the average then
for both of these
i will get the same value so it means
that from the
graph embedding point of view these two
no these two graphs will have the same
embedding value
so they'll have the same representation
so we cannot differentiate we cannot
separate them out we cannot classify
them
into two different classes because they
have the same representation they both
have the
uh the representation of zero
so this is one issue kind of uh uh a
very simple
uh kind of edge case example um
why why global pulling uh many times can
lead to unsatisfactory results
especially if the graphs are
larger a solution to this
is to do a hierarchical pulling and
hierarchical pulling would mean that i
don't
aggregate everything together at the
same time but i'm
aggregating smaller groups and then you
know i take a
few nodes aggregate them i take another
subset of nodes aggregate them
now i have two aggregations i further
aggregate this and this way i can
hierarchically
aggregate things uh subsets of nodes
together
so let me give you a toy example and
then i'll tell you about how one can do
this
so imagine i will be going to aggregate
using a
rectified linear unit as a non
as a non-linearity and a summation as
the aggregation function
right and imagine that i decide to
aggregate hierarchically in a sense that
i first aggregate
first two nodes then i aggregate the
last three nodes
and then i aggregate the aggregates
right so
for graph one how will this look like is
i first aggregate
minus one and minus two um and then pass
it through
value i get a zero then i aggregate the
last
three nodes uh here's the aggregation i
get a value of
3. now i aggregate 0 and the 3 together
and i obtain a 3. so this means the
embedding of this graph g 1
is 3 because we work with single
dimensional embeddings right
now for g2 here is my uh here's my graph
right so again if i do the i if i do the
first two nodes
the value will be zero if i do the
second uh
the last three nodes the uh
the value output of this aggregation
will be 30.
if i now further aggregate this using
the same aggregation
function so i aggregate 0 and a 30
i will get a 30. so now the two graphs
have very different embeddings
one has an embedding of three the other
one of thirty so we are able now to
differentiate
right we are able to distinguish them
because they have different embeddings
they
they do not overlap in the embedding
space
so that's an idea or an illustration how
hierarchical pulling may help
so now of course the question is how do
i decide who tells me
what to aggregate first and how to
hierarchically aggregate
and the insight that allows you to do
this really well in graphs
is that graphs tend to have what is
called community structure
right if you think of social networks
there are tightly knit communities
inside social networks so the idea would
be that if
i can detect these communities ahead of
time
then i can aggregate nodes inside
communities
into let's say community embeddings and
then i can further aggregate community
embeddings into super community
embeddings and so on and so forth
hierarchically this would be one
strategy would basically be to apply
what is called a community detection or
a graph partitioning algorithm to split
the graph
into different clusters denoted here by
these different
colors and then aggregate inside each of
the cluster
each of the communities and then keep to
to create basically for each community a
super node this is now
an aggregated embedding of all the
members of the community
and then i could again look how
communities link to each other
uh aggregate based on that get another
supernode and keep aggregating
until i get to the prediction head right
and one option as i said to do this it
would be to simply apply
a graph partitioning graph clustering
community detection
uh algorithm to identify what are the
clusters in the graph what are these
densely connected groups
and then you would you know do this in
the level of the original network
then you would do this again at level
one you do this at level two
until you have a single supernode which
you then
can input into a prediction head
uh what is interesting is that you can
do this
actually in a way so that you learn how
to partition the network right you don't
need to
download some external software and make
this assumption that you know
communities are important what you can
do and there's a paper linked up here
called
diff pool because this is kind of
differential pulling operator
that allows you to learn how to
aggregate nodes in the network and the
simple idea how to do this is to have
two independent graph neural networks
at each level here and one graph neural
network is going to compute node
embeddings
this is standard what we have talked so
far but what is clever is that we will
also have a second graph neural network
that will compute the clusters that
nodes belong to so what i mean by this
is it will
determine which nodes should belong to
the same
cluster which nodes should be aggregated
together which embedding should be
aggregated together to create this
supernode and the cool thing is that
you can train gnns a and b at each level
together in parallel so this means that
you can supervise
how to cluster the network and how to
aggregate
the the networking for the node
embedding information
to to come up with the optimal way to
embed
uh the underlying network so this is
kind of the most advanced way
how you can do how you can learn to
hierarchically pull
the network in order in order to make a
good faithful embedding
of the entire network
so this is what i wanted to
show in this case now
that we have talked about prediction
heads
let's talk about actually the
predictions uh and the labels so the
second
uh part i wanna talk about uh is this
part here
which which is about uh predictions and
labels
so um we can broadly distinguish between
supervised and unsupervised uh learning
supervised learning on graphs would be
where uh
labels come from some external sources
perhaps
for example nodes have belonged to
different classes
users in social network you know
are interested in different topics uh if
you have graphs
molecules perhaps every molecule you
know
we know whether it's toxic or not not or
we know
how is it it's drug likeness which is
something that chemists
worry about right this is supervised
basically
supervision labels come from the outside
and then there is also the notion of
unsupervised learning on graphs
where the signal the supervision comes
from the graph
itself an example of this would be for
for example
a link prediction task right where you
want to predict whether a pair of nodes
is connected here
we don't need any external information
all we need is just
um pairs of nodes that are connected and
pairs of nodes that are not connected
and sometimes the difference between
supervised and unsupervised
is blurry because both you can formulate
as an
optimization tasks and in both you kind
of still have supervision
just in some cases supervision is
external and sometimes
supervision is internal right so
um you know for example if you train a g
and n
uh to predict node clustering
coefficient you would kind of call this
unsupervised learning on graphs because
the supervision
is not external and sometimes
unsupervised learning
is also called self-supervised right
basically
it's the data that said that the the
input data gives you the supervision to
the model so a
link prediction task is an example of a
self-supervised
learning task right where basically we
take the unlabeled data but still define
supervised prediction tasks based on the
structure
of that data so
let me first talk about supervised
labels on graphs
so supervised labels come from specific
use cases
and let me give you a few examples right
for node labels
you know you could say oh in a citation
network perhaps a
subject area that a node that a paper
belongs to
that's my external label it's defined
for every node
for example in um
in link prediction for pairwise uh
prediction tasks for example in a
transaction network
um i could have the label y to for every
transaction to tell me whether that
transaction is fraudulent or not right i
have some external
entity that tells me verifies every
transaction and says
which ones are fraudulent and which ones
are not so that could be the label
is it fraudulent or not and you know for
entire graphs for example if i work with
molecules
as i said drug likeness or toxicity
would be an example of an externally
defined
label that we can now predict for the
entire graph
for the entire molecule and you know
one one advice is is that to reduce your
task
to a note edge or a graph labeling task
since these tasks are standard and easy
to work with right so
um what this means is that sometimes
your
machinery modeling task will will come
in as a
not as a node classification task or as
a link prediction task
but if you can formulate it as one of
these three tasks
this means that you can reuse a lot of
existing research and you can reuse
um a lot of existing methodology and
architectures right so having casting
the prediction tasks in terms of these
three fundamental graph level tasks
definitely helps because it's easy
because you can lean
on a lot of prior work and prior
research so now that we talked about
supervised tasks
let's talk about unsupervised signals on
graphs
the the idea here is that sometimes we
only have a graph
and we don't have any external labels
and the solution here is to define
self-supervised learning tasks right so
the models will still be
be the same there will still be the loss
just the supervision signal will come
from the
input graph itself so what are some
examples of this
for example for node level tasks you
could say
let me predict statistics such as node
clustering coefficient or pagerank
perhaps what one opt should also be that
if you work with molecule molecular
graphs maybe you would say
let me predict what type of atom is a
given node right is it a hydrogen is it
a carbon
is it oxygen that would be one way of a
self-supervised task in a sense that you
are trying to predict some attribute
some property
of that node um for link prediction for
red let
edge level tasks uh very natural ways to
self-supervise
is to hide a couple of edges and then
say can i predict whether a
pair of nodes is connected or not right
can i predict whether there should be a
link or not and that's a
level of self-supervision and then for
graph level tasks
uh again we can think of different graph
statistics for example
we can say are two graphs isomorphic um
you know
what kind of motifs graphlets do two
graphs uh
have um and you could use this as a way
uh
to supervise uh at the graph level right
um and notice that in all these tasks
that i defined now
we don't require any external ground
truth
labels we just use the graph structure
information and whatever
is the input data
so now that we talked about uh
predictions
uh and labels now let's discuss the loss
function
and and talk about you know what kind of
loss functions would i use to measure
discrepancy between the
prediction and the labels uh so that i
can then optimize this loss function
and basically back propagate all the way
down to the parameters
of the graph neural network model
so the setting is the following we have
n data points
and each data point can either be an
individual node an individual graph
or an individual edge so for node level
prediction
we'll say aha each node has a node i
has a label and here's the predicted
label for edge level again we'll say
each edge
has a each potential edge has a label
and we are going to predict that label
label could be does the edge exist or
not maybe it's the type of the edge
whether it's fraudulent or not and so on
and similarly last write for
graph level i'm denoting this as g you
know for each graph
we have the true label the true value
versus the
predicted value and i'm going to use
this notation y hat
and y to refer to the prediction uh
to the prediction predicted value and
the true value
and i'm going to omit the superscript
sorry the subscript
so that will basically to denote what uh
prediction specific prediction task we
are talking about because at the end
y is just an output and i can now work
with these outputs and compare
the y hat versus y
so an important distinction is are we
doing classification or are we doing
regression
classification means that labels y
have discrete categorical uh values
right um it would be you know what topic
does the user like
while in regression we are predicting
continuous values you know wanna predict
drug likeness of a molecule or toxicity
level
of a molecule right binary prediction
would be our classification would be is
it toxic or not
regression would be predict the toxicity
level
and gnns can be applied to both of these
settings to classification
as well as to regression and the
difference will be
between classification regression is
essentially in the loss function
and the in the evaluation metric so
let me first tell you about
classification loss the most popular
classification loss is called cross
entropy we have already talked about
this in lecture six
where basically the idea is if i'm doing
a k way prediction
for i the data point then cross
entropy between the true label and the
predicted label y hat
is simply a sum over um all these k
different classes uh the
y value of the at that class
i data point times the log uh predicted
uh
class value and y hat you can interpret
as a probability
um and the way this basically works is
to say the following right you can
imagine that
my uh y is like this so this is now a
binary vector that tells
that my um particular let's say node
belongs to class number three
so it is a one hot label encoding and
then you know the
y hat would now be um a vector
a distribution perhaps we can apply we
applied soft max to it
so it means that all this entries sum to
1 and this now you can interpret as the
probability that
y is of class number
number three and the idea
is if you look at this equation right
because the the
the predicted probability the
probabilities will sum to one
what we want is that um wherever there
is a value
of uh the true class is is not
uh here we want the probability there to
be very high because
zero times anything is zero so we want
uh it we want the probabilities
uh to be to be low here because log
something close to zero gives me a high
negative value but if i multiply it with
zero it doesn't matter so i would wanna
uh predict low numbers here but wherever
the
the value is one i wanna predict a high
probability because
um here i'll be multiplying with one
but log of something that is close to
one is
zero so again the cross entropy loss the
discrepancy in this case will be small
so basically this
this loss will force the predicted
values
uh to the cloud to other classes that uh
data point i does not belong to to have
low values
and where whatever class it belongs to
it will force it to have high value
that's the idea because if this is one i
want the second term to be as small as
possible
the way i make it small is to make it as
close to one
as possible right remember that these
entries have to sum to one
and this is now loss defined at a single
data point i
so the total loss is simply a sum over
all the data points
and then the cross entropy loss for each
individual
data point so this is in terms of
classification loss
uh the most popular one for regression
loss
um what is a standard loss is called
mean squared error
or or equivalently also known as the l2
loss
and essentially what we are doing we are
saying aha if i have a kva
prediction task i'm trying to predict k
real values for a given node
i i'm simply summing over all the k and
i'm taking the discrepancy between the
true value
minus the predicted value and i square
that so that this will always be
positive
and basically the idea is right the the
loss will take the smallest value
when y and y hat are as aligned as
possible so
when these differences are as small as
possible
and the reason why we like to take the
quadratic loss here is because it's
smooth it's continuous
it's easy to take derivative of um it's
always positive
a lot of kind of nice properties so
again this is a loss
mean squared error loss uh on on a on a
pair on
one data point and now over if i have n
training examples
then i simply sum up the losses of
individual
uh data points and this is now the the
loss
on the entire data set
so this is in terms of classification
and regression loss
there are also other losses that we like
to use
for example there are these losses
called maximum margin losses
that are very useful if you don't care
about
um predicting a binary value or a
regression
but you care about the node ordering
perhaps you want to sort the nodes
according to
according to some value and the idea is
that what you carry is
for the nodes to be sorted properly and
you don't care so much what
exact values they have you want to know
who are the top k nodes
in this case you would use some kind of
triplet based loss is called
because you want to enforce one node to
be ranked higher
than than the other node or you would be
using
some kind of much max margin types loss
so now that we talked about loss
functions let's also talk about
evaluation metrics so for evaluation
metrics
um we i for re how we evaluate
regression
is that we generally compute what is
called uh the mean squared
squared error and the way this is
defined is
again it's the square difference between
the predicted value and true value
you define you you take the average so
you uh divide by the total number of
data points and then you take the
square root so this is kind of analogous
to the uh
to the l2 loss that you optimize
this is now how you report performance
uh
of your model you can also do mean
absolute error
where now you just take diff absolute
differences and divide
uh by the number of data points um if
you look into
sk learn so the psychic learn python
package that all of us will be using
during the class
there is a lot of different metrics
already
implemented there and here i just give
you uh two
most common ones uh for classification
uh you can uh what is a very standard
way to report is what is called
classification accuracy where basically
you just say what number of times did
my predicted uh variable predicted class
match the true class and you say what
fraction of times did i
correctly predict the class uh this is
nice
a metric if your classes are
about balance balanced means that i know
half of the data points is positive and
half is negative
if you have very imbalanced classes
imagine that you only have
one percent uh positive class
data points and 99 are negative then the
problem
with accuracy is that it's very easy to
get high accuracy
by just predicting uh negative class all
the time
right so if i if i'm for example
um if i have the case where i say is a
front transaction
fraudulent or not and let's say 99
of transactions are non-fraudulent then
my
my i can get very high accuracy of 99
if my classifier always says uh
non-fraudulent right so this is the
problem with accuracy is that if classes
are in balance
then trivial classifiers may have very
high
uh accuracy so
uh to get more uh to go deeper and and
to deal with some of these issues
um there are other metrics that are
more sensitive to this decision what do
we
do what do we call us positive and what
do we call as negative because
the the models will usually output let's
say some probability a value between
zero and one
and we have to decide on the threshold
to say everything above this threshold
is positive
everything below the threshold uh is
negative um
and the precision recall type metrics uh
are one example to do this um and there
is also the
rock auc so the area under the receiver
operating
characteristic that i'm also going to
discuss
and talk about so first is if you want
to know more
than just accuracy then what you can
define is this notion of
what is called confusion matrix where
you basically say aha
what is the predicted value is it
predicted positive or negative
versus what is the actual the true value
is it positive or negative
and then you can count how many examples
how many data points are each
in uh in each of these four cells right
when you correctly predict
negative you you do plus one here when
you correctly
predict a positive you do a plus one
here because predicted an actual match
and then you can make two types of
mistakes called
false positives these are examples where
you predict that positive but they are
actually negative
and you then also have false negatives
where
you predicted negative but the class is
actually positive
so accuracy is simply true positives
plus
true negatives divided by the sum
of all of them so this is here right
it's the number of data points
precision it's called out of all um
it says how many true positives are
there and i normalize this by true
positives and false positives so
precision says out of all the positive
predictions i made
what fraction of them are true and then
recall says
um it says again through positives but i
divide by two positives and false
negatives
right so i'm basically saying out of all
positive examples in the data set how
many did i actually predict positive
right so recall says out of all
positives in the data set how many i
have predicted positive
and precision is out of predicted
positives how many are actually
positive um and then you can combine
precision and recall
into some into a single metric that is
called uh f1 score
uh defined as two times precision times
recall divided by precision plus
recall this formula is a harmonic
mean of precision and recall that's why
it is defined this way this is harmonic
mean or harmonic average
of precision and recall in information
retrieval
in text mining people like to use f1
score
a lot and then the last
evaluation metric that i want to talk
about is a rock auc so basically a
receiver operating
characteristic or receiver operating
characteristic
curve and this measures the trade-off
between the true positive rate
and what is called the false positive
rate um and
true positive rate is really recall and
false positive rate is def
divided by false positives divided by
false positives plus true
uh negatives and the way you usually
write it is that you
you you you draw true positive false
positive rate versus true positive rate
and and this um evaluation matrix
comes from the field of uh medicine
where basically you
rather than thinking of it as what who
is i know who is sick
or not or you can kind of think of it as
you sort people by
risk of having a disease and now you can
imagine
uh asking ah i will take top two top
three top four
and you ask how good is the top how good
how clean are the top k candidates
because
this classification threshold that
determines who
what what points are positive and what
points are negative
in some senses uh arbitrary and
what is interesting if you uh take the
positive and negative examples and
randomly sort them then the then you
would get this
true positive versus false positive rate
it will be a straight line
so a random classification will give you
a straight line
and then um if you do better
classification than
random then uh this uh this particular
line is going to approach
uh kind of more and more uh this top
corner here so if if it would be a
perfect classification
basically it would go up immediately and
then remain flat
so the uh the metric that people like to
use to
to characterize the performance of a
classifier
is the area under the roc curve
right so a random classif classifier
will have the area of 0.5 because it
covers half of this square and a perfect
classifier
would have an area of one so
rock auc is the area under this
roc curve this this is called the roc
curve
and the higher the area the better the
classifier
uh on a random classifier has an area of
0.5 so
0.5 is not good 0.5 is bad it's
basically random
um one intuition what the area
under the aoc uh the uh roc curve tells
me is
it tells me the probability that if you
pick two
uh a positive and a negative point at
random what's the probability that a
positive point will be ranked higher
than a negative point so if it's one
this means you gave a perfect
classification
all the positive points are ranked above
all the negatives
and if you give a random classification
then the probability that the positive
is above a negative
is is half because uh it's random right
so
um this is one intuition about the auc
curve so um we have talked about
the training pipeline today um about
how do we define the prediction head we
talked about the
evaluation metrics we talked about where
the labels come from
and we talked about the loss function
what we are going to
talk about next week is we are actually
going to talk about how do you set up
training
how do you do training how do you set up
the data sets
how do you split your data between test
valuation
um and training data sets
to be able to do efficient training
and to get good results